Bon, c’est parce qu’il est le patron !
Ah oui, quand même !
Non, mais en fait, c’est un vrai salaud
!
Peut-être savez-vous que Steve Jobs, le célèbre
entrepreneur à l’origine des produits phares
d’Apple, et qui est idôlatré pour cela,
avait la réputation d’être humainement
détestable.
Je suis Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Selon les témoignages de ses employés, Steve
Jobs était tyrannique, voire souvent foncièrement
méchant.
Certains sont même restés traumatisés après
avoir travaillé dans ses équipes.
Moi, je vais éclairer ce comportement avec
la théorie de l’entrepreneur de l’économiste
Joseph Schumpeter.
Il la présente notamment dans Capitalisme,
socialisme et démocratie.
Avec cette idée, vous allez mieux comprendre
pourquoi Steve Jobs était un salaud.
Quel portrait psychologique de Steve Jobs
pourrait-on faire ?
À partir de la biographie de Walter Isaacson,
mais aussi des deux films qui sont sortis
en 2013 et 2016,
je dirais que Steve Jobs est intense,
obsédé - ou concentré, si on veut -
et colérique
- très colérique -
Du coup, il ne laissait pas ses interlocuteurs
indifférents.
Ça, c’est normal pour Schumpeter, parce
que la psychologie et le comportement de l’entrepreneur
ne sont pas ceux de l’acteur économique
normal, celui que les économistes appellent
l’homo oeconomicus.
Cet homo oeconomicus, il aime la routine ; alors
que Steve Jobs valorise ce qui est exceptionnel,
notamment dans le design.
L'homo oeconomicus, il fait de petits calculs
économiques de court terme pour protéger
et améliorer son bien-être ;
Steve Jobs, lui, avait un grand projet à
long terme, très risqué, et qui lui demandait
de ne pas économiser ses efforts.
Pour Schumpeter, en effet, l’entrepreneur
ne cherche pas un surcroît de jouissance
; il trouve sa satisfaction dans l’effort
lui-même.
Enfin, l'homo oeconomicus est plutôt conservateur,
alors que Steve Jobs, et plus généralement
l’entrepreneur, est un révolutionnaire.
Steve Jobs ne se satisfait pas du monde tel
qu’il est.
La plupart du temps, il ne se satisfait pas
non plus des choses qu’on lui présente
:
il peut dire brutalement que « c’est de
la merde » - et encore ça c’est une version
gentille -
il peut demander de retravailler le design
des dizaines, des centaines de fois.
Steve Jobs était d’une exigence extrême.
Parce qu’il n’est pas là pour ajouter
sa petite touche, pour faire le n+1ème ordinateur
ou smartphone.
Non, ce qu’il veut c’est une révolution.
Schumpeter qualifiait bien l’entrepreneur
de « révolutionnaire de l’économie ».
C’est même pour lui l’acteur essentiel
de l’évolution économique, un agent radicalement
différent du producteur et du consommateur
tels que conçus par la théorie économique.
Dans la perspective de Schumpeter, l’entrepreneur
vit en quelque sorte en dehors de l’économie
standard, dont il bouleverse la logique gestionnaire
et utilitaire.
Schumpeter explique que créer de nouveaux
produits et services, que choisir de nouvelles
méthodes, eh bien ça ne va pas du tout de
soi.
C’est même plutôt contraire à l’activité
économique traditionnelle, et aussi, quelque
part, à la nature humaine, qui est attachée
à la sécurité et à la prévisibilité.
Mais des personnages extrêmes comme Steve
Jobs prennent le risque d’essayer de découvrir,
dans la masse des innovations scientifiques,
celles qui permettent d’augmenter la productivité
ou, comme l’iPhone, de satisfaire une demande
non encore révélée.
Sans l’entrepreneur, le progrès technique
resterait lettre morte, il ne serait pas diffusé
dans la société.
L’entrepreneur a donc pour Schumpeter un
rôle crucial dans l’économie : il est
à l’origine de la création de richesses,
d’emplois, du progrès technique, et de
l’amélioration du bien-être.
Mais il y a plus : il y a une dimension presque
mystique chez l’entrepreneur.
Et tout particulièrement chez Steve Jobs.
Si il y a bien une chose qu’ont retenu les
personnes qui ont cotoyé Steve Jobs, c’est
son intensité.
Quand il était concentré sur un sujet, rien
d’autre n’existait ;
quand il croyait en une chose, personne ne
pouvait l’en faire démordre.
Cette intensité, elle était notamment transmise
par son regard.
Cette manière qu’avait Steve Jobs de fixer
intensément ses interlocuteurs les troublait
profondément.
Certains racontent qu’ils se sentaient vraiment
percés à jour par ce regard, qu’ils avaient
la sensation de ne pas pouvoir cacher leurs
pensées.
Comme hypnotisés, ils perdaient leurs moyens
et se soumettaient aux exigences de l’entrepreneur.
Cette anecdote, elle illustre l’intensité
de l’homme habité par une vision.
Pour Schumpeter, c’est surtout ça finalement
- la vision - qui fait que l’entrepreneur
est un agent économique exceptionnel.
Il est capable de voir les choses sans pouvoir
les justifier, par intuition.
C’est un peu un guide mystique.
On retrouve tout particulièrement cette dimension
chez Steve Jobs, qui était fasciné, depuis
son adolescence, par la spiritualité orientale
et ses exercices pratiques, comme la méditation
ou les diverses formes de jeûne.
On l’oublie parfois, mais le fondateur d’Apple
était un peu un hippie au début.
Porter sa vision coûte que coûte, contre
vents et marées, ça donnait à Steve Jobs
un charisme particulier qui réussissait à
embarquer les plus sceptiques dans ses aventures.
Regardez dans ce petit extrait vidéo comment
il était charismatique.
L’entrepreneur de Schumpeter a une vision
dans le sens où il est capable de se donner
à lui-même un horizon inconnu, radicalement
incertain, qui ne relève pas de l’anticipation
rationnelle, et d’y mettre toute sa foi.
Il est à la fois motivé par le désir de
renouveler la réalité économique et par
l’ambition de créer un empire qui soit
le signe de sa puissance.
L'économiste ajoute, dans sa théorie, deux
éléments intéressants :
Le premier, c’est qu’il voit un rôle
sociologique à l’entrepreneur.
Pour lui, l’entrepreneur ne vient pas de
la bourgeoisie ; il est un aventurier inspiré
dont les valeurs et la psychologie, tout entiers
tournés vers le risque, sont contraires à
l’éthique bourgeoise, elle vouée à la
sécurité et au confort.
Mais l’entrepreneur à succès s’agrège
à la bourgeoisie ;
grâce à lui, la classe bourgeoise se revivifie
et se renforce pour gagner la lutte des classes
- ce qui serait impossible, estime Schumpeter,
sans les qualités de cette personnalité
supérieure.
Le second élément supplémentaire intéressant
de la théorie de Schumpeter, c’est que
l’entrepreneur serait une espèce en voie
de disparition.
Parce qu’il constatait, dans la première
partie du XXe siècle, le développement des
monopoles et qu’il anticipait la stagnation
économique du système capitaliste,
l’économiste a prédit dans ce livre l'avènement
de l'économie planifiée, ce qui veut dire
que l'entrepreneur était appelé à être
supplanté par le planificateur comme élément
moteur de la société.
Bon, on peut dire sans trop prendre de risque
qu’il s’est trompé.
Steve Jobs est loin d’être le dernier entrepreneur
schumpétérien ; il a même été dépassé
assez rapidement, en fait.
Aujourd’hui, il semble moins impressionnant
en comparaison d’un Jeff Bezos ou d’un
Elon Musk.
Qui seraient eux aussi, de ce que j’ai pu
lire, des salauds.
En synthèse, si Steve Jobs était un salaud,
ce pourrait être parce qu’il avait vraiment
la psychologie d’un entrepreneur ; qu’il
était un innovateur très exigent ; et qu’il
n’acceptait aucun compromis pour sa vision.
Bon, maintenant, je dois reconnaître qu’il
y a des limites importantes à mon propos.
Il ne faut pas se laisser abuser par la mythologie
de l’entrepreneur.
Elle ne prospère peut-être pas à toutes
les époques, mais en tout cas à la nôtre
ça me semble certain, avec l’aura de la
Silicon Valley.
La mythologie de l'entrepreneur, elle est
entretenue par la légende de Steve Jobs ;
mais la théorie de Schumpeter lui donne aussi
beaucoup de crédit.
Je suis d’accord pour dire que l’entrepreneur
est utile à l’économie, mais pas pour
dire qu’il est une personnalité supérieure.
L’entrepreneur, ça n’est pas que Steve
Jobs, Elon Musk, ou Jeff Bezos ;
ce sont aussi, et surtout, le boucher, le
boulanger, et le marchand de bière, pour
parler comme Adam Smith.
Même s’ils ne révolutionnent pas l’économie,
ils lui sont très utiles (à leur échelle)
- et peut-être même plus que les entrepreneurs
stars.
Enfin, la mythologie de l’entrepreneur,
elle a également tendance à gommer le fait
que les grands accomplissements sont forcément
le fruit d’une équipe.
Alors certes, un entrepreneur comme Steve
Jobs a réussi à coordonner et à guider
de grands talents individuels, mais il est
raisonnable d'imaginer qu’on lui prête
beaucoup plus que ce dont il est effectivement
à l’origine.
Mais bon, « on ne prête qu’aux riches
», comme on dit.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse de la conception de
l’entrepreneur de Schumpeter, ou pour lire
directement Capitalisme, socialisme et démocratie,
les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.